the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing I recently
watched a video with pi Morgan Abby
Martin and one
uncivilized
uneducated ill bred
UNC whose only qualification seems to be
his
association with or his being the son of
the co-founder of the very organization
he despises the most Hamas and that is a
pathetic irony but what is even more
pathetic is what we're about to witness
let's take a look at him try and
articulate himself in the English
language uh listen it's Israel
responsibility to know the death of
their own citizens this is their
responsibility I don't think I think
your question was absurd this is why you
put him on the spot he was not prepared
for it but this is not going to change
the reality on the ground the reality on
the ground Hamas must go I the only uh
side want Hamas to stay is the Iranian
ayat and for some stupid reason Karen in
America wants Hamas to stay but the Arab
world let me tell you something Jordan
Egypt Saudi Arabia the majority of the
Arab world we are Arabs I am Arab we are
not Palestinians we don't want Hamas we
don't want Islam we want islamists out
of power okay it's as simple as that all
right so you can see with this man's
articulation that English English
language is not his strong suit neither
is logic neither is presenting facts
because everything he said can be
dismissed because that which can be
presented without evidence can be
rejected without evidence and he's made
a series of points which are assertions
requiring statistical evidence of course
he's not a man of evidence or a man of
Education as I've mentioned is an ill
bred uncouth without a qualification to
his
name but to the rescue comes Abby Martin
let's take a look at how she responds to
the questions of Pi Morgan because
Israel's been committing ethnic
cleansing and genocidal policies against
the Palestinians for 70 Hamas literally
has a charter AB hang on Hamas literally
has a stated Charter of the elimination
of Israel that is the purest
personification of a publicly stated
policy of genocide I can
imagine that's not true their revised
Charter says that they actually
recognize the existence of the Israeli
State among 1967 borders that that's the
revised Charter and they actually make a
political differentiation between
Zionism and Judaism when they
official pointing to you keep pointing
to a random spokesperson yeah yeah but
he's the he's actually he's not random
he's the official spokesman for Hamas
and he said literally two weeks after
October the 7th we are going to do this
again and again and again that is an
existential genocidal threat to the
existence of everyone in Israel clearly
said publicly on camera it he's braising
about it look I think that when you're
comparing one guy and his statement to
literally genocidal statements okay but
look at the official spokespeople of
Israel peers and look at the ACT
genocide they're commit cannot compare
you cannot compare the two it's a
complete false equivalency one guy is
saying one thing the other dozens of
Israeli ministers and cabinet officials
and public media personas on TV are
saying one thing and actually doing it
on the ground you would allow her master
to stay in power now that was a very
elegant and exceptional and impressive
performance by a woman who's been put
under pressure yes by pi Morgan to a
lesser extent but more so by this
uncouth this uncivilized
uncouth and unfortunately this
embarrassment to the Arabs this Abu
jahal this father of ignorance
individual had to be put in his place in
a very fine and elegant manner you see
the difference between the two
presentations was aside from the English
language
proficiency on the uh side of the latter
presentation compared to the former
presentation is that Abby Martin
actually cites evidence and that's what
made Piers Morgan
dumbfounded and and this is what he does
I mean when he's caught out on a point
he just stays there in silence
and he just kind of looks a little bit
embarrassed as he did when he was
scrambling for words in the historic
discussion with myself but that's
something else I'm very happy and proud
that we have westerners here in the
anglosphere who are able to present the
case the prop Palestine case and it does
give us hope in humanity and it does
show you that this case is not just for
Muslims or for Arabs or for Palestinians
that you can be a conservative you can
be a liberal you can be whatever you are
and still accept that this what we're
witnessing is a genocide and it's a
Holocaust by
missiles and
that the invasion of RAF is just one
chapter in this long 70y year story of
Injustice and oppression absolute
Injustice and
oppression so what we do is we thank
everybody including Abby Martin and
everybody else like herself who's Who's
Got The Bravery really to speak about
this case in the way that they're
speaking about it and putting people
like this treacherous clown to shame and
one thing I will say to those proponents
of the worst or the Zionist movement who
want to take this man who's a traitor to
his people to the Arabs to the Muslims
to the Palestinians to humanity yes he
want to take him as an ally to give you
your secrets and this and that and
whatever is that a leopard never changes
his spots and treachery is one of those
ingrained
characteristics if you know that this
woman has cheated on her ex-husband then
you'd be a fool to marry her because a
leopard never changes his
spots and a weasel like this mosad will
never be able to change his russet Brown
back and
creamy white throat and
belly hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for no way you know this and I know
this so that makes the reward even
greater so give generously and Allah
will give you even more